no legal commentator on cable news is
more energetic constitutionally minded
or libertarian than Andrew Napolitano
censorship is a very dangerous business
who has served as Fox News's senior
judicial analyst for nearly two decades
a former New Jersey Superior Court Judge
Napolitano is a nationally syndicated
columnist you can read him regularly at
reason.com
and the author of a shelf full of books
about law history and race in America
reason caught up with the judge at
Freedom Fest the annual event held every
July in Las Vegas we talked about Donald
Trump's ongoing makeover of the federal
judiciary whether Supreme Court nominee
Brett Kavanaugh will be good for the
Libertarians what it's like to be an ex
Republican and the imminent return of
Freedom Watch the popular and
controversial show that Napolitano
hosted on Fox Business from 2006 to 2010
Judge Andrew Napolitano thanks so much
for being on my show the one man I want
to question me no holds barred the
pleasure Nick it's always a pleasure to
be with you topic of the day is Brett
Kavanaugh a Supreme Court nominee a lot
of people particularly on the right
among libertarians are pretty happy with
this pick you don't hold as high opinion
of him as well I hold a high opinion of
his of his academic credentials and I
was intellect but not of his values my
candidate on that list would have been
Senator Mike leaves the only legitimate
qualified libertarian that was on the
list also the only non judge on the list
I was very disappointed with the
appointment of Cavanaugh because I
believe that he comes from the heart and
soul of the Washington establishment so
if you if you like the people that run
Washington DC no matter which parties in
power you call them the establishment if
you don't like them you call them the
swamp so when the president was mr.
Donald Trump he was calling this crowd
the swamp now he calls this crowd the
same human beings the establishment they
are the ones that thrust judge Cavanaugh
upon him right come on he you're saying
is part of the establishment he went to
high school with Neel Gorsuch at
Georgetown Prep he's got two degrees
from Yale lived in DC most of his life
works in DC that's a problem yes that's
that I've expanded why that is that is
not the fresh blood that Donald Trump I
promise but I'll give you two examples
and they both involve the Fourth
Amendment but he believes that the
Fourth Amendment does not apply to the
NSA that it only applies to law
enforcement meaning that the America's
domestic spies generally called the NSA
there are other domestic spying agencies
at the president's disposal can capture
our keystrokes and our telephone
conversations and our whereabouts
without a search warrant because he in
in his very narrow without historical
precedent but influenced by recent
events view of the Fourth Amendment it
only applies to evidence that's going to
be introduced in court so the police can
spy on me if they're not gonna introduce
that evidence into court in Brett
Cavanaugh's world the NSA can spy on me
and you and are doing so now because
there's at least three iPhones in this
room you can't turn them off so they're
recording if if they want to listen
they're recording what we're saying and
he sees no impediment to that he has a
similar view of the Fourth Amendment
with respect to law enforcement and that
is bending over backwards to find a
creative ways for to justify police
access so if the police plant a GPS
device on your car to see where you're
going
he would have no problem with that even
though the Supreme Court valid yeah and
he would say you don't need a search
warrant you don't want this you know
reasonable suspicion this stuff has got
to be turning Madison in his grave and
one of the great linchpins of the
American Revolution was the Stamp Act
and the writs of assistance act
abbreviated you had to have a stamp on
every piece of paper in your house and
British soldiers did not need a warrant
in order to get into your house these
two cities sure that the stamps were
everything and correct correct it cost
more to enforce this legislation that
was generated in tax revenue now George
the third was stupid but who would have
a tax that costs more to collect the
you actually collect unless the purpose
of it was not to collect money but to
remind the American colonists that the
king could come in their house whenever
he wanted so this issue of privacy has
been front and center and was front and
center with the framers and needs to be
front and center today and Brett
Kavanaugh is on the wrong side how does
so he's terrible on kind of Fourth
Amendment and police power or police
search seizure various defendants rights
issues he's good on things like the
administrative state he seems to be
interested in saying to Bureau
bureaucracies and agencies now you don't
get to set your own rules Congress does
that and you can't just make them up
like we'll say you know if you ever
reach that's invalid we're gonna make
Congress do so so here's his argument on
the administrative state and with one
exception I agree with him
and this is an argument rejected by
Justice Scalia and accepted by Justice
Gorsuch the statutes today create the
administrative state the Food and Drug
Administration the Environmental
Protection administration the Securities
and Exchange Commission the theory is
that they're populated with experts who
can regulate minutely certain areas of
the law that is generally beyond the
congressional intellect if you'll pardon
those two words together congressional I
just had a mini-stroke right and and the
statute basically says that when they
write a rule they enforce the rule and
they interpret the rules so let's say
you want a mud puddle in your backyard
and the EPA decides it's navigable
waters and therefore you cannot dry it
up and you have to protect it and you
can't build anything around it and you
challenge that rule the challenge goes
before an administrative law judge who
works for the EPA they wrote the rule
they enforce the rule they interpret the
rule you lose you then sue them this is
where judge Kavanagh is view and justice
course it just you comes in the statute
says you do not enter court as equals
you enter court with a court giving a
presumption of validity to what the EPA
did the Gorsuch Kavanagh non Scalia rule
is that's absurd there's no reason for
us to defer to them you come into a
federal court you are equal on that I
agree with them my problem is there is
one administer
agency that he arbitrarily exempts from
that the NSA yeah back to where we stood
yeah well and I guess that answers my
next question in a way but I was gonna
ask you how in you know when you think
about the law and a Supreme Court
justice how do you say okay well what
what is the most important thing so he's
great on nine things out of ten but then
the tenth thing has to do with Fourth
Amendment so he's out or how do you I
mean your what's your personal well if
I'm the president I'm looking for
someone more like or such so I'm looking
for someone who believes in the primacy
of the individual over the state and of
course it's just the only one that
believes that way Clarence Thomas to a
certain extent that our rights are truly
natural that they don't come from the
government that's not an academic
argument because of our rights are
natural the president can't take them
away and the Congress can't take them
away the courts can only recognize that
we have waived them the bank robber
waives his right to freedom when he
breaks into the bank and steals the
money but the legislature can't declare
him a bank robber or the president can't
declare a prank because they think he's
going to break into the bank because his
freedom is natural if he were on the
same page as Justice Gorsuch on the
primacy of the individual he would
probably come out the same way that I
would on many of these issues but he's
not I don't know that the president got
into the weeds with him on that the
president knows he's pro-life pro-gun
pro-police
just those three are enough to sell to
this president's base and of course I am
with him on to pro-life pro-gun but I'm
Pro fourth amendment would you say that
Trump one of the arguments that a lot of
supporters you know push forward is that
regardless of all the other stuff you
know and he's terrible on trade he's
terrible on immigration I think we agree
on that oh yeah terrible you know he's
not as good on foreign policy he you
know one would hope that he would be
less interventionist and less bellicose
yes but he's remaking the federal
judiciary in a way that is consistent
broadly with a kind of libertarian
perspective do you think that's valid
I think it's valid that he's making the
remaking the federal judiciary
with an eye toward ideology far more
than any republican president in your
lifetime in mine including Ronald Reagan
I'm gonna use this raise even though
it's a criticized phrase the litmus test
that's applied during the process of
becoming a federal judge really is an
ideological one today so they're
interested in those three issues
pro-life pro-gun pro-police I wish it
were a pro-life pro-gun Pro Constitution
or Pro Fourth Amendment so is he putting
people like Randy Barnett or yours truly
on the court
no he's putting more traditionalist
conservatives who will support that
mantra of pro-life pro-gun pro-police
on that list that was pulled off of
ideas from the Federalist Society and
the Heritage Foundation Mike Lee was the
only libertarian candidate who was
qualified who was on that list what
would make Mike Lee a great Supreme
Court justice
well senator Lee is is an intellectual
eye I guess I'm going to reveal a secret
here although I've said it publicly he
and I text each other almost every day
and we often split ideological and
almost theological here's a note about a
great deal there's a lot of emojis in
those talks I don't what is Mike Lee's
favorite emoji I don't use emojis and
when they created me they are sent me
something with a water skier turned out
he was the water skier he is a serious
intellect he clerked for my Princeton
classmate who's our bedrock of
conservatism on the court Sam Alito and
still my friend you're just are you a
New Jersey Exceptionalist here you just
you just want you're mad that more
people from Maryland are on the Supreme
Court and with Scalia leaving and now
it's just Alito right we are there were
more people who believe in the primacy
of the individual over the state who
recognize natural rights and who takes
seriously this if the government derives
its powers from the consent of the
governed do you know anybody that has
consented to the government suppose I
vote for the people that lose if
I can sent it to the government that's
in power this is not just an academic
argument this is the linchpin but the
Declaration of Independence how do you
square that then without having without
loosing mirror and anarchy on the world
can't you can't change it today without
some sort of gradualism but to me the
only valid role of government is to
enforce people's natural rights that's
to Jefferson also but we thanks to the
civil war and the Progressive Era and
the New Deal and LBJ and everybody sends
him we're in that into this monster
government which in ran called an
inversion an inversion because the
government that Madison gave us we know
everything about the government and they
know nothing about us now they listen to
every phone call we make and they
operate largely in secrecy the
government needed its permission to
attack our permission attacks and
regulated us now we need the
government's permission to do almost
anything look around this room it's
almost impossible to find something
that's not regulated by the federal
government including the dye that's
turned to this whatever it is red I'm
gonna give you an opportunity to give a
spiel for your your alma mater Law
School Notre Dame is that where you
really went deep on natural law or
higher law theory Justice Gorsuch and I
in different eras and at different
schools were fortunate to study under
John finis fi nnis who along with Robbie
George of Princeton are the leading
academic lights in the natural law in
the world today
John finis was at Notre Dame when I was
there it was at Oxford when justice
Gorsuch young Neil Gorsuch was at Oxford
Judge Amy Kony Barrett and I studied
under the same brilliant scholar of the
natural law of American constitutional
law and American jurisprudence the late
Professor Charles rice Charlie rice was
on the Regan shortlist of five from
which Justice Scalia was chosen
professor rice Nina Scalia and three
others
Charlie rice had a profound influence on
Judge Barrett and on me on the natural
law and the natural law teaches that we
can discern right and wrong
and we can ascertain the truth by the
exercise of Reason and we don't need the
government it also teaches that our
rights come from our humanity and not
from the government you can accept that
teaching whether you believe we are
creatures of an all-knowing God you know
I'm pre-vatican too or you can accept
that teaching whether you just recognize
that we are the highest strongest most
effective rational beings on the planet
how does that apply then when you get to
a theory of governance that that would
just mean what 90% of contemporary
government in all levels would disappear
but yes yes which is why it couldn't
happen overnight because that would I
guess it was TS Eliot you know unleash
the forces of anarchy you know TS Eliot
was a fake Catholic it was an Anglican
name it's a JV Catholic judge I don't
know isn't there a Catholic poet okay
but I got to tell you when we did the
research it turns out that that ray
Catholic who was the most libertarian of
the Final Four is a high North American
Anglican so somebody Fox said to me what
the heck is that
I said that's more Catholic than almost
any Catholics you'll find particularly
what Francis and the papacy said that
but I do love TS Eliot but the fear of
anarchy being loosed upon the world if
this attitude which is essentially that
the government can only do what the
Constitution authorizes it to do that's
Madisonian that doesn't really change
take the civil war out of it because
people were killing each other that's
the that's the attitude of the
government up to Woodrow Wilson from
Wilson on forward it's the opposite the
government can do whatever there's a
popular will for it to do and it's
prohibitions are just those express
prohibitions in the Constitution that
too is an inversion that was a hundred
years ago if you were to rewrite that
inversion overnight there would be Eliot
or not Anarchy loosed upon the world so
how do you do that you know think put on
not your judge hat but your kind of
politician head or your policy how do
you how do you start rolling that back
in a way that doesn't immediately either
cause so much social unrest there's a
problem or the people the opponents of
going back the state we live in now you
know really muster their forces get
their army of Orcs or whoever and just
shut every well there'd be tremendous
resistance to rolling it back the
government employees so many people the
the deep state against which candidate
Trump railed until he appointed one of
the foremost in their number to the
Supreme Court earlier this week
basically has such control over so many
aspects of our society
law enforcement diplomacy finances the
fed intelligence military that the
resistance would be unbelievable so I
don't know that this could happen in
your lifetime our minor the lifetimes of
people watching us now other than by a a
revolution now if you said to Yeltsin I
mean really ever gonna get rid of
Eastern Europe those countries are
Poland is someday gonna be free after
what's happened in the past seven years
hey stranger things have happened you
for a long time we're a Republican or
you may still be a registered Republican
but you haven't voted for a Republican
candidate for president by your own
admission since Ronald Reagan what III
think it's clear to anybody who's
familiar with your work why you are not
you know simpatico with the Republican
Party
tell me emotionally what does it like to
grow up as part you are a Goldwater
Republican you you know you you believed
in this and that revolution seemed to
happen between Goldwater to Reagan what
is it like when you look at the
Republican Party now and it's like this
this is my tribe so I'm a registered
Republican where I reside in Northwest
New Jersey a lot of my friends in and
out of the government are Republicans
and I vote in the Republican primary and
I obviously vote in the general election
but I haven't voted for a Republican
candidate for president since Reagan I
have voted for the libertarian candidate
because the National Republican Party is
just a mirror image of the Democratic
Party both parties want to stay in power
both parties want some sort of welfare
whether its individual welfare or
corporate welfare both parties love war
both parties love taxes Republicans love
deficits a little bit more than taxes
which is basically taxing the future so
they don't the Republicans no longer
stand for what Goldwater argued in 64
and what Reagan argued in 80 now Reagan
in my view was just as co-opted by the
people around him as president Trump has
become with respect to the appointment
of justice or a judge Kavanagh so the
Reagan of 1988 with the exception of
some wonderful things he said was a
different human being than the Reagan of
1980 that argument that he made in the
third paragraph of his inaugural address
he would never make at the at the end of
his term that argument was let me remind
you that the states formed the federal
government and not the other way around
of course if I had been the Scrivener I
would have added and the powers that the
states gave away they can take back and
say that what would have to happen for
the Republican Party or who are the
people in the Republican Party that
would have to dominate it to get to get
your votes I don't know that these are
the right people because of personality
and leadership but certainly their ideas
of Ron Paul Rand Paul Mike Lee sometimes
Jeff Flake these are a distinct minority
in the Republican Party quite frankly
Nick I don't know where the Republican
Party is going there may be no
Republican Party there may just be a
Trump party because he is willing to rid
himself of longtime traditionalist
Republicans when they publicly disagree
with him and he seems to command enough
support from the base that he believes
he can get away with that it's very
interesting phenomenon and the Democrats
seem to be going farther and farther
left I had an interesting experience it
did something other why I'm laughing in
a minute I did something I've never done
in my life I testified before the Senate
I testified before the Senate Homeland
Security Committee against the corker
Kane bipartisan proposal to expand the
president's war-making powers and a
senator not on the committee showed up
to grill me this senator was not aware
of my opinions he was just aware of the
f
Oh X on my forehead who was this the end
of the grilling he said to me in his
though he doesn't represent New York
Brooklyn accent Oh George Napolitano you
still employed by Fox News after this
performance so is bernisa where's Bernie
Sanders what up hugging me because my
boss has been thrilled at the photo some
burning and I hugging each other but it
is an exhibit only two Republicans
showed up who agreed with me Rand Paul
and Mike lead all the other
interrogators were Democrats who were
ecstatic at what I was saying that
there's something called the separation
of powers and the Constitution says the
Congress declares war not the President
and this piece of legislation will let
the president declare war even against
the domestic organization and then
Congress could undeclared yeah after
he's buried them into smithereens that
was the argument was a lot of fun does
Brett Kavanaugh get confirmed yes I mean
this this would require me there's some
odd stuff coming out about his personal
finances this would require really odd
personal things to come out Rand Paul's
gone from a no to a I'll have an open
mind Susan Collins has gone from a no to
all have an open line John McCain's not
going to vote so they will need every
single Republican I probably have a few
Democrats to spare and who knows you
know people change ask those pro-life
judicial nominees Sandra Day O'Connor
and Anthony Kennedy and David Souter
what happened to them when they got on
the court judge is a final question
you're at Freedom Fest you are going to
be making a pretty fantastic
announcement about a new development
what is that freedom watch you remember
that show because you were on it that I
had on Fox Business is coming back to
Fox do we have a timeline for this
probably before Thanksgiving that I
can't tell you how excited I am about it
okay so freedom watch is coming back
this was just one of the most fantastic
shows when it was on Fox Business it I
mean you went to places that most people
were afraid to even think about what are
your hopes for the show what do you what
are you gonna be doing what are the
issues that are forming
in your mind the issues of human freedom
and how the government no matter who
runs the Congress who runs the White
House who's on the court continues to
wear away at our freedoms I mean if I
could short-circuit this very very
similar to the freedom watch that you
and many people listening and watching
us now knew and loved and lamented the
departure of that is something to watch
out for and really look forward to thank
you so much you're welcome for reason
i'm nicholas bee
[Music]